[Applaudissements]
il va falloir une grande inspiration
[Musique]
je sais ce que tu es 4
une fille de l'enfer
il faut que cela reste notre secret son
sein je ne pourrai pas te protéger me
protéger de quoi tes démons
je crois ici une vision une fillette aux
cheveux verts
réel
bonjour nous sommes les croque-morts
enchanteur les artistes de la vie après
la mort
et que nous sommes tes maîtres nous
tordonnons de faire de métaux et
dans vos rêves
sont en train de ressusciter une armée
de cadavres
mes démons donc mes problèmes je le jure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour le Seigneur l'annonce de ma mort
a été quelque peu exagéré
il arrive toujours des trucs horribles
aux gens dont je suis proche
il meurt
[Musique]